hello I'm Shane too long from the
running communications i'm coming from
yemen and i was attending this war
economic forum and now i would like to
take this opportunity to answer the
questions one of the questions of the
how well is asia contribute to global
economic rebalancing and growth so
regarding with that questions from my
pathetic view the issue is a very
important role in the global economy so
the ASEAN is part of the East Asia so so
one of the example is that of all of our
country you know we are between the the
two wall largest population country is
like China India so it's representing
the you know one third of the global
population so so that so if we can
balance and if we can create the
sustainable business and services in
this region that will be we are very
close so we can be we can get a very
good market and very good opportunity in
the global economy thank you